kurt jesse gentlemen welcome to the
forge
the two of you are about to take part in
the third battle in our gladiators of
forge competition series
now kurt you know how this goes but
jesse this round is going to consist of
eight hours of blade spinning
competition where you're gonna build a
blade from start to finish now first
things first gentlemen we need to find
out what blade from our ever changing
wall of roman gladiator weapons you guys
will both be building today i'm thinking
the copis
the copas traces its origins back to 7th
century bc greece but proved such a
powerful fighting weapon it stood the
test of time and remained popular
throughout the roman empire featuring a
wide recurve blade that was designed to
deliver deadly slashes and an enclosed
guard that protected the hand this
one-handed weapon proved popular with
cavalry soldiers and gladiators alike
the copas previously made an appearance
in the forging fire arena back in season
five where the competition came down to
the finest details
place miss good luck your time starts
now
i end up starting with 18 layers because
i don't think i'm going to need all 20
pieces for this blade so right now i
stretched my billet out i'm going to cut
it up into five pieces which will
overall give me 90 layers and it'll make
that raindrop damascus stand out a lot
more once i'm comfortable with the shape
of the blade and the bevels i'm getting
ready to quench this is the most
important step because
without the quench and hardening your
blade you have something that looks like
a blade but it's not a blade
kurt's question
ah under the neck
it sounded like there was a crack uh oh
fighters start over right now i don't
know if i'd be able to finish a blade
things are looking a little questionable
for current right now
not seeing anything which is very
relieving so i start working on this
animal head pummel i draw what looks
like it might be a horse i don't know
what it's going to look like when i'm
finished but right now i'm kind of going
for a horse this handle is a lot more
detailed than any of the other handles
he's already done there's a much bigger
gap between the handle and the guard
than what i wanted if you do have gaps
fill them
mix mix some sawdust with some epoxy
because anyone in those small areas
can really bite a piece of skin
i'm running out of time my handle is not
pretty it doesn't look nearly as good as
i wanted so i'm now back to i'm going to
be spending every minute and i'm going
to have a gap in my handle now
currently i'm a sophomore at the
university of michigan and i'm double
majoring in electrical and mechanical
engineering
oh my god that's so nerdy coming into
this competition i'm a little bit
nervous i'm up against curt who's
already won twice which means he'll be
thinking more calmly than me but
otherwise i think i've prepared well for
the competition
jesse's out of the forge
doing a hammer set first before heading
to the press
20 layers is too little for an intricate
raindrop so i decide that i have to
stack it up at least three times which
will give me 60 layers
whoa
jesse also got all of his drops drilled
in so after i have all these holes
drilled it's time to flatten out the
billet and get the actual raindrop
pattern and then once i have that it's
time to start forging out the blade ah
okay
i've got my blade forged out pretty
close so i go over to the grinder and i
begin
roughing out the profile
now that i've got this blade rough
ground it's time for the heat treat
the quench could not have gone better i
test it with a file skates like nobody's
business
now that i've got a quench blade it's
time to start working on the handle a
bad looking handle could be the
difference between me winning and me
losing i also need to get this animal
head to look like an animal head because
at this point it's just a block and
as far as i know no animal has a block
as its head
five
four
three
two
one
bladesmiths turn off your machines put
down your tools this competition is over
here nice job
all right blade smiths welcome to the
strength test
[Music]
to test the strength and durability of
your blades as well as our overall
construction i'm going to be chopping
onto these roman busts all right jesse
you're up first you're ready for this
yes
cool
[Applause]
all right jesse your
edge is perfect like it never saw that
bust the overall shape is really good my
main concern is is with the handle area
this distance top and bottom is just a
little bit too small so it's rubbing on
my knuckle as i'm holding it but it's
not overwhelming all in all nice job
all right kurt
you know what's up you ready for this
does it matter
not really
i'm concerned about the weight of my
handle i'm also concerned about the
finish i do want to hold the title
so
[Applause]
all right kurt
first off your edge held up great
pattern you have on here is beautiful
it's a really nice raindrop pattern well
done moving back to the handle the
handle is blocky which kind of
isn't a very comfortable handle to hold
and swing also it's got a gap in the
middle and the inside edges of that gap
are sharp they're sharp enough that
they're rubbing pretty hard on my
knuckle
but all in all
blade held up great in this strength
test nice job thank you
[Music]
all right gladiators this is sharpness
test the animal hides slice
jesse you're first you ready for this
of course
let's do this
[Music]
[Applause]
all right jesse let's talk about your
copis here your edge is razor sharp it
cuts so cleanly on this animal height
overall sir your weapon
you'll cut
curt your turns are you ready slice it
up will do
[Music]
[Applause]
all right curtis talk about your copis
here now your handle construction if i
do put my hand in there my knuckle can
get in there and there's some sharp
edges that can cut some skin but your
edges cut very well on this animal hide
and overall sir your weapon
you will cut thank you doug
well gentlemen i would say that both of
your copies performed extremely well
during a test which means that our
judges have a very difficult decision
make and the winner of this battle and
the gladiator of the forge competition
is
jesse
very very well done now kurt you did a
phenomenal job you're a pleasure to
watch but unfortunately this blade
didn't make the cut and ben's gonna tell
you why well kurt this decision came
down to the handle and your handle with
sharp corners on the inside was less
refined than your opponent and that's
what we based our decision on
unfortunately your time in this
competition has ended i'm gonna have to
ask you to please step off the forge
floor
thank you gentlemen
i might not have won this challenge but
i am proud of everything that i've done
so now i'm passing on the title to jesse
and i really hope he runs with it he
seems like a very talented smith and i
have high expectations for him
now jesse you knocked the leader off his
pedestal you are now the gladiator of
the forge and you're getting a check for
five thousand dollars jesse you got a
big decision to make you just spent
eight hours fighting it out in the forge
and you came out on top but do you have
what it takes to get back in the
coliseum and get back in the battle of
course absolutely it's fantastic
it's unbelievable i don't know how i got
here well congratulations again on your
win in the five grand we will see you in
the forge for the next battle i just won
five grand i'm gonna be doing my
absolute hardest to keep winning because
that's what i came here to do
you